what you guys want to hear a rap about
the beach let's pick an aspect of the
beach such as a specific beach or maybe
something you might do a beach seagulls
seagulls at the beach I like it thank
you very much this rectangle here what
you guys gonna suggest you said kartha
you said alcohol
what a lovely combination that's is that
what you said yeah yeah cool okay well
suppose we'll combine that somehow I
wonder how seagulls at the beach cars
and alcohol this tranche here what okay
vaginas any raised on vaginas from
people in the back
what braids vagina braids thank you very
much vagina braids car alcohol seagulls
the beach find a little tribute pursuit
wedge here what's your suggestion gonna
be colors p.m. maybe pick something
interesting do with colors like
synesthesia or how we learn colors wait
so uh I said synesthesia which is the
thing where you see colors is flavor the
smells you said anesthesia which I love
so I'm going to say anesthetic colors
vagina braids alcoholic cars seagulls
the beach let's take one final
suggestion come from anywhere
you said cannabis and you said what
Michael Cohen
okay Michael Cohen and cannabis will
combine those two as well this is a very
combination e-wrap Michael Cohen in
cannabis vagina breaks Eagles at the
peach alcohol and cars and what was your
one that we said honestly anaesthetic
colors you might need to remind me this
lovely people of Hermosa Beach a little
treat for y'all a little thing called a
freestyle rap
that is a rap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions it's never
even perform before it'll never be
performed again and do not worry it will
not be anywhere near as atrocious the
embarassingly toe-curling bad as you are
expecting it to be
only five of you seem convinced but
that's okay do you want to drop that
beat let's just see how we do
it's getting up Michael Cohen in
cannabis cars and alcohol C goes to the
beach for China parades and as their
colors is going to be fly I'm excited
and you can crank a little bit as well I
think that's fun yeah this 6-iron
I'm excited my profession yes my trade
sit in a strip mall vagina braces why do
if you come in - um your tois I'm gonna
get the hair gonna start a plaque go one
two three
you're understand that's we'll all those
strands in each of my hands move over I
know the pattern yeah wanna do it I just
start chatting let me explain to you why
I'm doing this long hair down there yet
when you piss might get cool off so if I
are care like cornrows in new yuria yo
you read from an area if you've got
those braids not Scalia I'm saying my
gosh
you look so great nice ball rolls in
your hole mate anyways yeah like no
other let me put you to sleep like a
very dull color if I want to go to the
better get down I use anesthetic so and
look at the brown beige maybe kind of
like boat
yeah no seat there's no way to hope if
it's more exciting than red or yellow
then I'll stay away yeah never be
another car that's easier you need it
for surgery let me get a color yeah I'm
deserted me I'm gonna get some bit like
purple if you're awakened it'll be
hurtful go for the operation such and
gos say Chris yank at you but your nose
what you inserting anesthetic no just
some Crayola Crayons go forget it yeah I
can't her for the insurance so they
never color yeah they employ other
people not to drink and drive on the
highway if you're doing yeah you would
be in a bad way get pulled over by the
cops they say please who will you drink
you better stop I just showed them say
Carson and or to be careful and metering
the balls of water but this one is full
of gin doesn't matter what a tricky
because internal step my chin because
there ain't one day yeah
the wheel I get it for $5.00 that's a
nice blue steel I get vodka bring it in
from Russia alcohol and caffeine have
discussion don't drink and drive because
you'll end up killing someone and that
is just not that freely next in you know
where I'm going
need a new job with a man Michael Cohen
what he's inside in the prison in the
jail need to get alarmed money and you
know he's gonna fail because
economy-wise not got any cash needs to
go store drugs in his cash he doesn't
have one though what have we saw maybe
still cannabis in his back door gets it
out in a cellophane wrap brings it up
here and he's doing the trap trap deal
is what's making me look when I see
Michael Cohen he's selling drugs go into
the cholos right in the yard same please
sir I think I'm real hard I was the best
friend of the president but now my
predicament is not pleasant and present
locked up inside these are more drugs
and cannabis are provide even though
it's legal in this state it's not inside
when you're locked up mate
Mike apparently you need turn away next
min I'm gonna fly straight right to the
beach after this by the shore never seen
so many seagulls before then
[Applause]
employer they are carrying carrying away
all the little things that I'll leave on
the beach today I put a little chips put
a little sandwich all the seagulls come
down together trying to steal this
coming down there yeah yeah a handful
favorite song seagull is a pet realm
this is her bird the voice when it
scared really cannot be aware we get
steeples they're so cruel learn about
the secrets of biology school I was
doing a bee is stuff that stuff oh gosh
this rap going quite rough I think we
did the five things so we'll finish
there there you go guys strike home sent
a girl
[Applause]